[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Hey, everyone.
Welcomes to "Eyes
On Enterprise,"
where I'll be
bringing on Googlers
to talk about how the technology
landscapes are changing
how enterprises adapt,
modernize, and scale.
My name is Stephanie
Wong, developer advocate.
And today, I have Yufueng Guo,
developer advocate for machine
learning on the show.
Welcome to the show.
YUFUENG GUO: Thanks
so much, Stephanie.
I'm really excited
to be here and chat
about machine learning.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
first off, just thinking
about some examples
of it, do you
have any that you've encountered
of specific ML use cases that
have come in and kind
of swept a company off
its feet a little bit?
YUFUENG GUO: Well,
the first kind
of big examples around these
came from image recognition
type use cases.
So on the one hand,
you have com examples
like Google Photos
really changing
how we think about
storing and searching
for pictures and other
kinds of recognition tasks
where you can auto tag images.
And then of course,
medicine is now
seeing a rapid
shift in diagnosis
in radiology, where they're
applying the technology
to find things more
accurately, and more quickly,
and more consistently
than doctors can,
because machines don't fatigue,
and they're always consistent.
They're not going to be upset,
because they were late for work
and stuck in traffic
earlier that morning.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And one thing I was
thinking about earlier
was machine learning versus AI.
I think there's a lot
of confusion there
about which term is
technically accurate.
So what's your opinion on that?
YUFUENG GUO: Classically
or traditionally,
AI was referring to the
broad field of just general
artificial intelligence AI.
And it was about systems that
were artificial intelligence,
and anything really
could apply to that.
Decades ago in the
'80s, a lot of these
were rule-based systems.
So there were
things that behaved
like an intelligence would,
at least how back then, folks
thought about it.
But they were just
rule-based systems,
if statements, and
things like that.
If this happens, then we'll do
this, and not terribly complex,
right?
But there were lots of different
approaches to doing AI.
So AI's kind of
the broad umbrella.
STEPHANIE WONG: Got you.
YUFUENG GUO: Machine learning
then becomes one set of tools
to try to achieve
AI, and it's possible
that we'll ultimately kind
kind of achieve or do better
in AI with some other set
of tools that isn't even
machine learning or maybe
evolves from machine learning.
And so a machine
learning is really
about some mixture of
statistical inference and kind
of training on some set of
data, and creating a model,
and doing these predictions.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Yeah, that's great.
I think there used a lot of
the times interchangeably.
But it's great
clarification to have,
because they really are
quite different in what
they encompass.
YUFUENG GUO: Absolutely.
STEPHANIE WONG: All right.
So let's talk about a typical
use case for an enterprise.
For a company that's
just looking to get
started, dip their toes
into machine learning
for the first time,
what would you
describe as the workflow
for them to get started?
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah,
so assuming that they
have some kind of system
they're trying to model,
some kind of task
they have in mind,
the first consideration
then becomes
checking to make sure
they have the data.
And if not,
collecting that data.
And so for example, if
they want to figure out
consumer preferences, they
say they're a retail store.
And so they'll collect that
data around kind of purchasing
patterns and things like that.
And many retailers
these days probably
have that data already that's
sitting around somewhere.
They've got to figure out
how to get their hands on it,
because it might be siloed
off, in different parts
of their organization,
and there are
people who might be
holding on closely to that.
And so getting access to that
in a way where you can aggregate
data together is important.
And then once you
have that data,
you can do analysis on it.
So that becomes kind
of the next piece,
looking at what data do
you have, is it useful,
are their signals in it?
And from there, you can do
kind of the traditional machine
learning training piece of
it, where you take that data,
train up a model, and then
deploy it to make predictions.
But we're not quite done yet.
Just because you've
created a model
and put it in production
doesn't mean that you can now
forget about it, and just let it
sit there, just as you wouldn't
leave production code out on
your website or its system
and just say, I'm done.
We don't need software
developers anymore.
This software is done.
It's just going to sit there.
That's not going to work.
And so models need to be
updated over time as well.
As purchasing patterns
change with the seasons,
with the years, that
information should feed back
and inform updated models.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
So content evaluation
of the model.
And then as things change,
you need to incorporate that
into the training.
YUFUENG GUO: Exactly.
So it's kind of,
in a lot of ways,
just like software development.
You need to maintain
your model over time.
STEPHANIE WONG:
So I want to dive
into that a little
bit more, because I
know that you had a
video that was very
popular a couple years ago that
was on the "7 Steps to Machine
Learning," and that included
gathering your data, data
preparation, choosing a
model, training, evaluation,
and hyperparameter tuning,
and then prediction as well.
So can you tell me about each
of the steps a little bit
in detail?
Who do you hire
for each of those?
And what are the trade-offs,
a little bit more about that?
YUFUENG GUO: Sure.
So with these seven
steps, so to speak,
there's no real, seven
steps, six steps, 10 steps.
You can break it out
however you'd like.
It was just really one
way to delineate it.
And a lot of times,
different steps
can be collapsed
into one job role.
It could be one week's worth
of work where you gather data,
and you kind of do that
data preparation, cleaning,
and things like that.
That might go together.
You might end up
making pipeline.
Whereas new data
comes in, and you know
how you'd like to transform it.
You can set up an
ongoing streaming
job where that data coming
in gets transformed and then
deposited in some kind
of data warehouse.
Then looking onwards to
things like training and model
development as well
as you alluded to,
hyperparameter tuning.
This is really the meat of
it, where a lot of people
spend a lot of their kind
of mental energy thinking
about modeling.
In a lot of ways, especially
for known use cases and kind
of solved problems that
aren't research bleeding edge
situations, you can use a lot
of existing state-of-the-art
models and adapt them for
your particular data set,
customize it, and get really
pretty much state-of-the-art
results for your data set.
STEPHANIE WONG: So I want
to go back to a point
that you mentioned earlier
about model evaluation.
Can you talk about why it's so
important for an organization
to consistently
evaluate their model?
Are there any use
cases that showcase
that it's so crucial or
failures that you've seen?
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah.
So we can take kind of a toy
example and work through it.
Right.
The data that you
are predicting on
needs to come from the
same world, so to speak,
that you've trained
the model on.
So this, in statistical
terms, means
your training, evaluation
tests, and all this data
needs to come from the same
distribution, essentially.
And furthermore,
that distribution
also needs to reflect the
reality of the world, right?
So there's two pieces to it.
For example, if,
let's say, we go
and we train a model
that can recognize
pictures of lawn furniture.
So chairs, and then
you go in the studio.
And you can take--
you're a chair company.
You make lots of
different kinds of chairs.
So you're going to make a
model, and then you maybe
you make an app that
people can hold up
their camera to the chair,
and be like, oh, yes.
It's this kind of chair.
Now, I can go buy one for
my mind as well or something
like that.
And so you bring in--
you set up a big
studio, and you bring
in all of your latest, hottest
chairs for the next season.
And you put it on nice
backdrops with good lighting,
and you take a bunch
of pictures and videos.
And you do up a whole shoot.
And you take that
content, all those images,
and you train a machine
learning model that
can recognize these images.
This is great if your task
that you're trying to make
is a model that can recognize
pictures of your products
in, say, your catalog, right?
Because those are the
same pictures basically,
and they will be in
the same situations,
and lighting, and all that.
But it doesn't really
help our actual use case
where they are going to be
in your customers' homes
with a backdrop of grass
and other-- the patio
and things like that.
It will be in the
context of other things,
so you've got to capture
data in the same world
that you're going
to be predicting on.
And furthermore, and this is
kind of the ongoing evaluation
piece, what happens
when winter comes
and that green
grass turns white,
and your model's never
seen snow before?
It's going to start
having problems.
And so this is why you need
a diversity of training data
in all sorts of scenarios
that is representative
of how you expect your model
to be seeing these images
during prediction time.
STEPHANIE WONG: So hence,
constant evaluation.
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
then just as important
to collect data
points of labels that
are the prediction that
you're looking for, but also,
examples where it's not that.
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
So in this particular
scenario, it
would mean also having
images of these environments
with your chair removed.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
YUFUENG GUO: So
just a normal lawn.
Maybe there's some
leaves on the lawn.
STEPHANIE WONG: So of
course, the question arises,
what if the validation
performance of the model
just isn't up to par?
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah.
I mean, poor model
performance can
come from all sorts of factors.
It includes things like
the raw modeling technique.
Maybe you don't
have enough data.
Maybe you're over
fitting on that data.
There's lots of possible
causes, and this
is kind of where expertise
and experience really
become valuable.
It's easy to follow
the kind of golden path
of just do this, and do this,
and do this, and it'll work.
But then when something
goes wrong, fixing problems,
that's where expertise
comes through.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And overfitting,
what do you-- can
you just describe what that is?
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah.
So overfitting is
essentially a way
to describe the fact
that the model has
memorized the training data.
This is bad, because it's
going to struggle them
with real predictions,
because all it knows
is the exact training there.
So in that example
with images, it's
basically memorized
these pictures and said,
I will only classify
this as a lawn chair
if I see this exact image
or these 10 exact images.
STEPHANIE WONG: So let's
say I have my problem,
I've collected the
data, prepared it.
What do I do to set it up?
And what tooling
exists out there?
What's the general
developer experience
for machine learning?
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah, so for
developing your own model,
there's a lot of
libraries out there today,
things like TensorFlow
being a prominent one
in the industry that's really
seen a lot of adoption.
Of course, there's
things like scikit-learn
which is, as I
mentioned earlier,
it's kind of a machine learning,
but not technically deep
learning.
It's deep learning adjacence.
But also, machine
learning is a toolkit.
And of course, there's also
things like Keras, and PyTorch,
and other deep learning
tools that can also
be employed to model
a given data set,
and then in terms of
a language like AR
which is more targeted
toward statisticians
who have a lot more experience
with that sort of thing.
You can also use it
for structured data.
Sometimes language models
will show up there,
but by and large, the industry
has seen this real shift
to using Python as
the language of choice
around doing machine learning.
STEPHANIE WONG: So I want to
talk about this by problem
type, because as you
said, a lot of industries
have their own
styles of data sets,
and they need to approach
it in the right way.
So can you talk about
how you would do that?
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah.
So I think the first question
you have to ask yourself
when you want to do some kind
of machine learning or data
science task is, is it
a descriptive problem?
Is it a predictive problem?
Or is a prescriptive problem?
So I know those are
kind of long words,
and they all kind
of sound similar,
so let's go into each
of those a little bit.
A descriptive problem
is really, kind
of your traditional classic
data analysis problem.
A lot of times when people think
they need a machine learning
solution, really, they are
just asking given some data,
can you help me find
some patterns in it?
I don't really know
what I'm looking for.
Can you just describe
some interesting things?
So dashboarding, putting up
some nice visualizations,
cleaning up the data so
that you can do that.
That is, in a lot of
ways, a good first step
to even doing other types
of machine learning tasks.
So that's descriptive.
And then there's
predictive, which
is much of what we classically
think of as machine learning.
You have your training data.
There is something you're
trying to predict, right?
And then you try to model
and make these predictions.
So that's something where you
have inputs in the real world.
And then you say, oh,
I predict that this
will be a good outcome
and things like that.
Or given a tweet, is
it a positive tweet
or a negative tweet,
things like that.
And then thirdly, we have
the prescriptive task.
And these are a little more
uncommon at this point,
because this is
where you are saying,
I want to build a system that
will tell me what to do next.
And so that has some element
of almost like, if we're
playing a game of chess
or something, right?
What is the next
move I should make?
And this system should
be thinking about,
what is my opponent playing?
And what kind of options you
have and kind of gaming it out.
So it's a little bit
of game theory in there
and things like that.
And so this is why it's a little
harder to do in the real world,
because such a system
would need so many inputs.
It can't just model the entire
known universe and be like, ah.
The perfect next move--
[LAUGHS]
STEPHANIE WONG: If only.
Yeah.
YUFUENG GUO: --is this.
Yeah, exactly.
STEPHANIE WONG: All
right, so I want
to talk a little bit
about processing,
because a lot of companies
are looking towards the cloud
to do training and production.
Is this the only viable option
to really do it at that scale?
Or is there an opportunity
for hybrid approach?
YUFUENG GUO: When you look
at it from the perspective
of your data set, if you
have a huge data set,
and you don't have any way
of really storing it on-prem,
and there's more data
coming in all the time,
there's only one answer.
Right?
But in a lot of situations
today, maybe you're
only interested in doing machine
learning on a certain slice
of data, on a certain subset.
And there, it might make
sense to do training locally,
and then deploy that to
the cloud alongside all
of your other applications.
There's a number of
different ways to slice
and dice the different
workflows in the cloud,
but it basically boils down
to self-service and managed
services.
And so a self-serve
situation would
be your classic make a
VM, configure it yourself,
put whatever you want on
it, run your training.
Now, maybe you put it
in a Kubernetes cluster
if you need more machines,
things like that.
And then on the
other hand, you have
managed services which are more
along the lines of putting up
a Python package or
putting up your code,
and then having this
man or service take care
of the provisioning, and set up,
and tear down of these machines
after they finish running your
job, running your training job,
and output that
exported model file.
In terms of thinking
about which one to do,
I think the big one
I've seen come up
in terms of why would you want
to serve a machine learning
model locally?
And that answer typically
is along the lines
of response time and latency.
So sometimes, you have a model
that goes on a mobile device,
and it needs to work
either more quickly,
or work in situations
with no connectivity.
And so then you would
shrink that model down,
put it on your phone, and
embed it into your application.
On the other side of
things, why would you
keep it on a local server
in your own data center?
Maybe you need to
be close proximity.
You need to be close to wherever
you're communicating to.
Typically that shows up in some
kind of financial situations
where you need to make kind
of millisecond decisions,
and these predictions are only
good for the next slight window
of time before, and the
markets change all the time.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, so it
makes me think of stock market.
And then on the mobile
side, IoT use cases.
YUFUENG GUO: Absolutely.
Yeah.
STEPHANIE WONG: So one thing
I've been curious about
was, how long training
needed to take,
and how many iterations does
a team need to go through
before achieving an
optimal model that they
can deploy in production?
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah, this is kind
of the quintessential question
about machine learning.
You can train a small
model on a moderate sized
data set in seconds, a
low number of minutes.
But if you have a
big data set, and you
have really high requirements
of accuracy or performance,
it might take weeks
even to train a model.
Some of these huge
research models
that are really pushing the
state of the art, they're
literally training
on hundreds of GPUs,
pushing petaflops of power--
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, wow.
YUFUENG GUO: --and doing
this for weeks on end.
STEPHANIE WONG: That's wild.
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah.
And at the end, you have a
model, and it's like, oh,
I hoped that worked,
because I just
burned all of this
computer and time,
hoping to get
something out of that.
But yeah, it really comes down
to what are you optimizing for?
How much do you care about
those accuracy metrics?
In a situation where maybe
you're making recommendations
on a website, you're
shopping, and it says, hey,
some other products that
are similar to this product.
If one of them is a little
bit off or looks weird,
it's not the end of the world.
STEPHANIE WONG: What's at stake
here is the real question.
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah, exactly.
But on the other
hand, in situations
like self-driving car
or a medical diagnosis,
these are literal life
and death decisions.
And so having a model that
is reliable performance
and accurate is way,
way more important,
and the stakes are much higher.
The self-driving car
use case is another one
where latency matters.
And so that's why you are not
going to see cars == signaling
that back up to the
cloud, be like, well,
should I turn left
or right here?
STEPHANIE WONG: You might run
into a wall at that point.
YUFUENG GUO: Exactly.
STEPHANIE WONG: So what
are our options at Google
to move from dev to prod
and have it work reliably
in production at that scale?
YUFUENG GUO: One
of the services we
have is the ClouDiA
platforms prediction
kind of managed service.
And all you really need to do
is take your exported model,
say, here it is, give it a
name, and you're basically done.
And so it's pretty
magical in that sense,
because it's an auto
scaling service.
So you don't have to worry about
provisioning infrastructure
responding to spikes in demand,
maybe during the holidays,
during weekends,
things like that.
And so it'll automatically
scale up, and then
automatically scale back
down when traffic dies off,
and all you have to
do is finish training
your model and kind of tossed
it over the wall in some ways.
I know it's said a lot that,
you don't want to just toss
the model over the
wall from your data
science team to kind of
your productionization team.
But if your model is being
deployed in production
by a service, and the data
scientists can basically
just do that themselves,
it's like one command,
then it kind of changes
the game in terms of where
you can spend your time.
You can focus on
getting good data,
getting good training outputs.
And then once that's
done and you're
ready to push it to production,
it's not like this onerous task
that you then have
to get another team
to handle and coordinate with
the modeling team and things
like that.
So it's really nice.
STEPHANIE WONG: I'm seeing
that as a commonality
for cloud in general.
We talked a little bit
about managed services
versus custom modeling.
And I know we have varying
options at Google as well.
Can you dive into that?
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah.
I mean, it all comes
down to your comfort
with kind of building, running,
and maintaining these systems
yourself and the expertise
you have in-house as well
as when you think
about do you want
this to be kind of an
investment in the long term?
Or is it something where you
wanted to just kind of work
in like had it be good enough?
Managed services, things
like AutoML, they're
going to be necessarily
a little bit more
constrained, because you can't
have them be fully customized.
That's the nature, by
definition, of this comparison.
STEPHANIE WONG: I
think that there's
the key point here for
those who don't necessarily
have the right skill sets,
or they don't have the time,
then that's a great option is to
utilize machine learning APIs.
And then even for those who
have experience with TensorFlow,
and I know TensorFlow
2.0 is out now.
But we have
libraries that people
can leverage instead
of reinventing
the wheel in creating a
model from the get go.
YUFUENG GUO: Exactly.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK, so I
want to talk about some
of the amazing use
cases, because I
know you've worked with
many companies in the past.
So industry use cases in
the medical field, IoT
that are really utilizing
the advancements in machine
learning and some of
the Google tooling.
YUFUENG GUO: Two
that come to mind
is, one is the kind
of advancements
on the medical side, right?
Diabetic retinopathy
is kind of this leading
cause of blindness, and
Google has made huge strides
in improving the diagnosis of
diabetic retinopathy, which
of helps prevent blindness
as a result, a kind of side
effect of diabetes.
And so that effort is kind of
ongoing, and the work they've
done in the kind
of publications,
for me, it was the first time
I'd seen a computer science
paper get published in JAMA,
in the Journal of the American
Medical Association,
which is like,
when does computer
science get to publish
in the medical journal?
So that was really cool.
On the other kind
of use case, I got
to work a little bit with
Rainforest Connection,
and they're a nonprofit
that kind of helps prevent
illegal logging in the Amazon.
And they have these devices
called Guardians out
in the forest, and
they're listening.
They're listening for the sound
of trees being cut down, right?
Because they listen.
STEPHANIE WONG: Wow.
YUFUENG GUO: So then they have
all of this audio data coming
in, and they need
to process that,
and they need to pick out
from there and recognize,
oh, there's sound from that.
And then they can notify
law enforcement, right?
And they can go out
and prevent that stuff.
STEPHANIE WONG:
That's really cool.
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah.
STEPHANIE WONG: I
love that, yeah.
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah.
So, and the other cool
thing about it is now,
they're taking that data.
They're saying, wow,
I have all this data.
And they're realizing what
else is in this data set.
They're hearing sounds of
animals, endangered species.
And they can start
using that information
to find movement
patterns of animals
throughout the jungle
which is just wild.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
OK, so we just covered
a lot of surface area
when it comes to
machine learning.
I mean, companies need
to think about having
enough for compute
and storage, the data
sets, the right
personnel, and then
constantly re-evaluating their
models as new data comes in.
So how can you kind
of digest all of this?
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah, it's
a real culture shift
in terms of making a company
and business data aware
and using data in an
intelligent fashion.
It's not going to
happen overnight,
but I think getting
started sooner than later
is really important.
And it's going to take
time, but it will really
transform how a
business can really
take advantage of
the information
that it already has.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
with all that being
said, what can people do to
get value out of ML right now?
YUFUENG GUO: Yeah.
I mean, it really
depends on kind
of where you're at in
terms of your experience
and what you already know.
But you can kind of think
about it in terms of,
do you want to do manage
services and APIs,
where you can get started just
understanding and digesting
some of these high-level
concepts about machine
learning and putting data
in and seeing what comes out
the other side, so to speak?
And if you already have
some familiarity with that,
then diving into
the tools directly,
whether you're using
TensorFlow or Keras,
and just trying it out.
There's tons of amazing
materials out there today
in terms of tutorials,
and guides, and workshops,
and videos.
Another area, if you're looking
to just play around with ML,
so to speak, from
a conceptual level,
Google has a set
of AI experiments
which are just a ton of fun.
You can try them
out in your browser.
STEPHANIE WONG: Also, you have
your show, "AI Adventures,"
so I'm encouraging everyone
to check that series out,
because he is going to
go a lot more in detail
on some of these topics.
Overall, please check out
of the blogs, the videos.
We're going to have the links
to what you just mentioned
in the description below.
I want to thank you
so much for being
on the show today, Yufueng.
I learned a ton.
YUFUENG GUO: Thanks
so much, Stephanie.
It's been a blast.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
also, please comment
on your thoughts on the
show, what ML projects
you're working on, the
tools you're using,
and your thoughts about
what we discussed today.
Thanks again for checking
out "Eyes on Enterprise."
[MUSIC PLAYING]